together with our collaborators we have  been building a growing online community  of bioinformaticians and training as a  result we have developed two key  technologies to make this program more  interactive the first one is a big data  analysis platform called the t-bioinfo  developed at the tower bioinformatics  research center the second one was  designed to supplement  the materials that are on the platform  with interactive coding tutorials as  well as practical projects that you can  analyze data from to really learn about  the application of the different machine  learning methods on the portal you will  find access to big data analysis tools  and high quality learning resources that  include courses projects and tutorials  these help simplify data for  visualization and use it to spot  relationships and patterns and complex  data sets these exercises will include  learning and practicing scripting and  understanding how to analyze and  visualize various omix data